VALENTIN DELEPLACE: Hi, Martin.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hey, Valentin.
I heard you wrote
a web app and would
like to run it in the cloud?
VALENTIN DELEPLACE: Yes,
I wrote a simple web app.
Also, I love
serverless, and I need
to deploy my app to the cloud.
Today, we'll explore
three different ways
I can make that happen.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You know I'm a big
fan of QR codes.
They're one of the
most underrated pieces
of brilliant technology
of the last decades.
MARTIN OMANDER: [LAUGHS]
Well, they're beautiful.
So what do you want to
do with these things?
VALENTIN DELEPLACE:
Today, I'll show you
a nice cloud app called
Hot Maze to transfer
a file from my computer
to my mobile phone.
For this, I could
plug a USB cable,
or maybe send myself an email,
or use Dropbox or Google Drive,
but I prefer QR codes.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK,
that sounds neat.
Tell me more.
VALENTIN DELEPLACE: I'll
make a very quick demo.
Here, I have a picture of
a gopher on my computer.
I drag and drop it here, and
bam, I'm generating a QR code.
Then I scan the QR
code, and then I
have the gopher on my phone.
That's it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, cool.
Does it also work with
video files or text files?
VALENTIN DELEPLACE: Yes, you
can send any file you want.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
So this is a cloud service?
VALENTIN DELEPLACE: Yes.
The most simple way to achieve
a transfer between the two
devices who don't know
each other very well
is to have the computer
upload to the cloud
and the mobile download
from the cloud.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
So where do you
host the web page,
and where do you
upload the files?
VALENTIN DELEPLACE: I
have a strong preference
for serverless, because I
don't have to manage instances
myself, because of cost--
I don't pay when
it's not in use--
and because of automatic
scaling in case
I have thousands of
friends using the service
at the same time to
upload their own gophers.
In Google Cloud, I'm spoiled for
choices of serverless computing
hosting options.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK, so
which one did you choose?
VALENTIN DELEPLACE: All of them.
There are several valid
combinations to choose from.
Let's explore three
possible options.
First, App Engine Standard.
I've been loving this
one even before the word
serverless existed.
See?
App Engine can both host my
HTML and static resources
and process what happens
in the cloud backend
when I drop a file,
executing my source code.
First, I created a
regular Go web server
that I tested locally
on my workstation.
Then I could deploy it without
modifying the source code.
This is the command line I
used to deploy to App Engine.
I chose Go out of six languages
available in App Engine
Standard.
On file drop, we
asked the web app
to generate two secure URLs--
one to let the browser
upload to Cloud Storage,
and one to let the phone
download from Cloud Storage.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
But so far, the server is
only connected to the web
page in the computer browser.
How can you push
anything to the phone?
You don't even know
its IP address.
VALENTIN DELEPLACE: That's
the beauty of the QR code.
The web page encodes the secure
download URL inside the QR
code, and this is all the info
that is needed for the phone
to retrieve the file
when scanning the QR code
and extracting the URL.
MARTIN OMANDER: Amazing.
So to summarize,
you did all this
using App Engine
and Cloud Storage?
VALENTIN DELEPLACE: Yes.
That was option number one.
Option number two is
Google Cloud Functions.
You see, functions are great
to quickly implement something
to do in response to an event.
For example, our
events are someone
just drag and dropped a
file, and someone just
scanned a URL QR code.
We also need to host
the web page itself.
And for this, I recommend
Firebase Hosting.
I have a command to deploy each
function and another command
to deploy the website's
static assets.
MARTIN OMANDER: So Firebase
Hosting for the frontend
and Cloud Functions
for the backend logic,
and Cloud Storage for
the temporary file?
VALENTIN DELEPLACE:
That's right.
Functions are a modern approach
for developing services that
are stateless, loosely coupled,
that process incoming events
and communicate with each
other by message passing.
They're a good fit for
fine-grained microservices.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
You said you had a third
serverless alternative?
VALENTIN DELEPLACE: Yes.
We can deploy the whole
thing, frontend and backend,
to Cloud Run.
For my app, it's very similar
to deploying to App Engine,
but with explicit containers.
So if you already have a
container-driven workflow
and use a container registry,
then deploying to Cloud Run
will be seamless.
You can also install almost
any binary dependency
you need in a container, which
is mindblowing, in my opinion.
If, like me, you don't
know that much about Docker
files and container
technologies,
though, you may like the
ready-to-use buildpacks
for deployment.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
Valentin, what's
your recommendation?
VALENTIN DELEPLACE: Well, the
three serverless solutions
work really well, because
the app design is stateless
and all these platforms, except
Go, has a backend language.
They all achieve
high scalability
and cost efficiency.
If you want to know more
about the small differences
in the developer experience
and in the infrastructure
more than trade-offs,
please check the articles
linked in the description.
MARTIN OMANDER: So I have
hundreds of photos and videos
of cats on my hard drive.
Could I use your app to
copy them to my phone?
VALENTIN DELEPLACE:
Photos of cats?
Really?
Yes, I guess you could
use my app for that.
Thank you for watching.
You can also find
the source code
for this app in the
description below.
Feel free to add any questions
you might have in the comments.
[MUSIC PLAYING]